in just a few hours drive from uvalde
gun advocates faced off with protesters
over the weekend outside the nra
convention in houston meanwhile the gun
violence continues since friday there
have already been at least 12 mass
shootings nationwide according to the
gun violence archive including one that
killed one person and wound in seven
more at a festival in oklahoma and
another that injured six people in
downtown chattanooga nicole killian is
on capitol hill nicole does congress
plan to address this
well nikki after yuvaldi there is a
sense here on capitol hill that this
time could be different a small group of
lawmakers is hoping to use the memorial
day break to cut through the partisan
divide on gun control
it could be your kids today
in houston a fierce divide between gun
safety demonstrators and gun rights
advocates outside the nra convention
guns are killing people and no one's
doing anything about it just banning a
gun
isn't going to stop anything on capitol
hill where lawmakers left for the
memorial day recess connecticut senator
chris murphy told face the nation he
believes congress can get at least 60
votes on gun legislation i do think
there's an opportunity right now to be
able to pass something significant i've
seen more republican interest in coming
to the table and talking this time than
at any other moment since sandy hook
murphy is leading a bipartisan group of
senators discussing proposals from
expanded background checks to red flag
laws which allow courts to temporarily
seize firearms from individuals deemed
to be a risk i think there's a lot of
problems with red flag laws especially
at a national level convincing
republican rank and file remains an
uphill battle though some seem willing
to budge raising the age of gun purchase
to 21 is a no-brainer at least three
states have pledged action on tougher
gun control laws in the wake of uvalde
arkansas governor asa hutchinson says he
wants to convene a bipartisan group of
governors but argues the focus should be
on school safety instead of guns ar-15s
were around for 40 years before they
were ever used in any type of mass
killing or attack it is about
identifying
the culprits and going after them
senate bipartisan negotiations are
expected to continue this week the house
is also working on its own package of
legislation and could vote on a red flag
bill as soon as next week jim
nicole thank you